das ist eindeutig eine rassistische
verzerrung und das bei einem digitalen
überwachungsprogramm der polizei in los
angeles 90 prozent 90 prozent der
personen die im visier der operation
laser stehen sind people of colour das
ziel des sogenannten predictive policing
es ist ein ganz anderes mit solchen
prognosen sollen verbrechen die
möglicherweise in der zukunft
stattfinden könnten verhindert werden
doch wie zuverlässig ist eine solche
prognose software die übrigens auch hier
in deutschland also ähnlich eingesetzt
wird wirklich und können unerwünschte
folgen überhaupt erkannt und behoben
werden klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt es spannendes science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktivierte
glocken nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen das wäre
wirklich zu schön um wahr zu sein eine
prognose software die besser
funktioniert als jeder polizeibeamte
dieser welt so könnten dann sogar
verbrechen vorhergesagt werden die
möglicherweise in der zukunft
stattfinden klingt auf den ersten blick
echt mal total bescheuert aber es ist
gar nicht so absurd in welchem haus
passiert der nächste einbruch wie
gefährlich ist die zielperson iks auch
in deutschland wird diese sogenannte
predictive policing eingesetzt zum
beispiel in manchen nrw städten wie mal
und dortmund gehe benutzt das
landeskriminalamt die software skala um
wohnungseinbrüche zu verhindern das
ganze basiert auf data mining wobei
statistik auf große datenmengen
angewendet wird unter welchen
bedingungen wurden bestimmte einbrüche
in der vergangenheit begünstigt und wie
sind die aktuellen bedingungen damit
kann man zum beispiel tatsächlich
diebesbanden auf die schliche kommen die
immer nach einem bestimmten prinzip
vorgehen das programm gleich das ab und
prognostiziert risikogebiete in denen
eine erhöhte wahrscheinlichkeit für
einbrüche besteht diese hotspots werden
dann auf elektronischem wege der polizei
vor ort übermitteln deutsche
sicherheitsbehörden berechnen außerdem
auf basis des predictive policing wie
gefährlich bestimmte terrorverdächtige
sind zu der arbeit von algorithmen
schreiben fachleute in einer großen
studie der bertelsmann-stiftung sie
können menschliche entscheidungen an
vielen stellen sinnvoll ergänzen denn
auch diese sind natürlicher weise mit
erheblichen schwächen behaftet etwa weil
menschen von subjektiven einschätzungen
geleitet werden oder weil die komplexe
steht einer sachlage schlicht ihre
zeitlichen oder kognitiven kapazitäten
übersteigt also auf deutsch entweder sie
haben zu wenig zeit oder sie sind zu
dumm
trotz dieser vorteile wird diese art von
polizeiarbeit heiß diskutiert denn bei
solchen daten gestützten prognosen kommt
es immer mal wieder zu fatalen fehlern
oder besser gesagt nebenwirkung was
macht jetzt auch das beispiel aus los
angeles deutlich mit dem
überwachungsprogramm operation laser
sollte die polizei kriminelle und
gangmitglieder ins visier nehmen und
diese personen aus den vierteln
entfernen und zwar mit einer zitat laser
ähnlichen präzision wie es von
offizieller seite heißt doch das ganze
ist nicht nur minimal gescheitert
sondern komplett nach hinten losgegangen
ende des vergangenen jahres 2019 nämlich
wurde öffentlich dass operation laser
fast ausschließlich people of colour
überwacht hatte 89 prozent der
überwachten personen waren schwarze und
latinos das alles hat die
bürgerrechtsorganisation stop lpd es
beim kohlschen ans licht gebracht und
zwar durch eine klage gegen die polizei
von los angeles
so wurden dokumente veröffentlicht die
diese rassistische verzerrung zeigen
haben mit kann der gründer der
organisation bezeichnet das in einem
spiegel interview als überwältigend und
erklärt weiter die schwarze gemeinschaft
hat in los angeles nur einen anteil von
rund 9 an der bevölkerung also ist es
eine verzerrung von fünf zu eins eine
verheerende erkenntnis denn gerade
polizeiarbeit sollte natürlich alles
andere als rassistisch sein und damit
hat sich die operation leser selbst ins
abseits manövriert das ganze ist
wirklich sehr problematisch weil es ja
tatsächlich so ist das schwarze die
unschuldig sind viel öfter verdächtigt
werden und das alles ist passiert obwohl
durch den einsatz einer solchen prognose
software genau das gegenteil erreicht
werden sollte damit sollen nämlich
objektivere einschätzung möglich sein
als jede polizeibeamten oder jeder
polizeibeamter dieser welt jemals
liefern könnte
die bertelsmann stiftung und die
stiftung neue verantwortung haben eine
große studie zu diesem thema in auftrag
gegeben und auch hier sind die fachleute
skeptisch es lässt sich nämlich nicht
einschätzen welche erfolge solche
prognosen wirklich haben so lässt sich
also über den erfolg von predictive
policing spekulieren denn er besteht ja
aus dem ausbleiben von kriminalität und
diese wirkung ist quasi gar nicht
messbar
dazu schreibt das autorenteam in der
studie der bertelsmann-stiftung wie gut
dass ein kreisen von kriminellen
stets hotspots funktioniert weiß man
nicht weil die wirkung sehr schwer
messbar ist andere mögliche
einflussfaktoren lassen sich nicht zu
isolieren dass man wirkungen und
mittelbar auch produktiv policing
zurückführen kann
die operation laser wurde mittlerweile
gestoppt gründer der bürgerrechts
organisation stop lp die spine kulissen
haben mit kann fällt ein vernichtendes
urteil er bezeichnet predictive volle
sing im gespräch mit dem spiegel als
eine zitat pseudowissenschaftliche
maskerade für die kriminalisierung und
überwachung gesellschaftlicher
minderheiten eine art formel mit der die
polizei der öffentlichkeit gegenüber
begründen kann warum sie tut was sie tut
und auch wenn das eben rassistisch ist
mich erinnert die ganze sache an das
ergebnis einer investigativen recherche
der journalistenvereinigung pro publica
dabei sollte eine software einschätzen
wie hoch das risiko einzelner
strafgefangener ist wieder rückfällig zu
werden
das problem die künstliche intelligenz
nahmen die hautfarbe der menschen als
entscheidendes merkmal dafür an
kriminelle energie auszuüben das hatte
der algorithmus so aus den trainings
daten abgeleitet und die stammten
natürlich von menschen und auch das hat
er damals schlimme folgen und erst vor
kurzem hatten wir hier bei pixum science
fiction über einen weiteren sehr
ähnlichen fall berichtet dabei ging es
um einen algorithmus den krankenkassen
in den usa millionenfach eingesetzt
haben und da wird wirklich deutlich wie
rassistisch dass auch sein kann wo es
gar nichts mit verbrechen zu tun hat die
software ist dafür zuständig über den
weiteren behandlungsverlauf der
patienten und patientinnen zu
entscheiden im einzelnen geht es darum
diejenigen kranken auszuwählen die eine
intensivere medizinische betreuung
bekommen sollten ein us forschungsteam
hatte den algorithmus genauer ins visier
genommen und untersucht wie die software
zu ihren ergebnissen kommen dafür haben
die fachleute viel arbeit auf sich
genommen und rund 50.000 krankenakten
händisch untersucht ihre ergebnisse
haben sie dann mit den ergebnissen des
algorithmus verglichen wie treffsicher
ist er wirklich bewertet er patientinnen
und patienten mit unterschiedlichen
hautfarben gleich die antwort ist leider
eindeutig und zugleich auch erschreckend
denn der algorithmus ist alles andere
als unvoreingenommen die software
diskriminierte schwarze patienten und
patientinnen und stufte sie deutlich
seltener als die hellhäutigen patienten
und patientinnen in höhe
risikoklassen 1 bei einem vergleichbaren
gesundheitszustand bekam hellhäutige
menschen deutlich öfter die bewilligung
für eine intensive medizinische
betreuung als die schwarzen patienten
und patientinnen
letztere müssen also einen deutlich
schlechteren gesundheitszustand
vorweisen um weitere hilfen bewilligt zu
bekommen
das autorenteam fasst es in seiner
studie folgendermaßen zusammen die
schwarzen patienten auf der gleichen
stufe der risiko rangliste hatten
dadurch eine signifikant höhere
krankheitslast als die weißen damit
zeigt ein algorithmus der die
gesundheitsvorsorge von millionen
amerikanern beeinflusst eine
signifikante rassen bezogene
voreingenommenheit ein schlag ins
gesicht für diese art der methodik hier
wurde der algorithmus geändert
gottseidank was drastische folgen hatte
statt 18 prozent bekamen plötzlich 47
prozent der schwarzen patientinnen und
patienten eine bewilligung für intensive
medizinische betreuung zweieinhalbmal so
viel heißt also im klartext künstliche
intelligenz ist mächtig mithilfe von
algorithmen können maschinen wichtige
entscheidungen treffen beispielsweise
bei versicherungen oder banken wo
mittlerweile nicht mehr nur menschen
sondern algorithmen darüber entscheiden
wer einen kredit bekommt und wenn ich
doch mittlerweile ist auch bekannt dass
genau das extreme folgen haben kann zwar
schlechte und deswegen müssen die
berechnungsgrundlagen und die
algorithmen ganz genau überprüft und
kontrolliert werden um unerwünschte
verzerrungen auf jeden fall zu vermeiden
die operation laser ja ich hab schon
erwähnt wurde mittlerweile in los
angeles gestoppt ist künstliche
intelligenz gut oder böse anklicken
anschauen und doktor watson abonnieren
kula kanal bis dann bleibt dran